as you know we met each other at an
improv class and this is one of those
crazy closing the circle moments
because we're wrapping things up here at
tbs yeah and
i'm getting nostalgic about all kinds of
things that i've been
involved with over the years like one of
the
i don't really precious memories of mine
is deciding when i first came out here
to la
85 that i wanted to do improv
and start trying to perform and so i
scoured around
i found that there was a class here at
this theater
yeah and i went there and
it was one of those classes was taught
by cynthia spaghetti you'd put money in
the jar when you came in
i came into this class and one of the
first people i saw
was you in the class this is how we met
yep
and um i immediately identified you
as someone really special and someone
really hilarious and talented who was
going to do big things
and we the the room where we met
is right there across the the little
courtyard and i thought it might be fun
have you been back to that room no yeah
so i thought it might be fun
here at the end of the segment if we
would just walk over
and check out sort of where we met and
and this is an
inspirational message to everybody who's
in a little improv class
i swear to god this is how you do it you
go there
you and you meet amazing people whether
it's an acting class an improv class or
doing stand-up in a club that's where
you meet people and you're young and you
have dreams and
it can really work out pretty
beautifully so i want to go check it out
yes
let's go we never hung out in this
courtyard because this was not where we
went but i think there was a gate i
don't remember even being allowed in
this
i don't think we were allowed in here
what would happen is we'd come here
and we'd hang out right here in this
alley yeah and how many people were in
the class
like ten there's like more 10 or maybe
12 people in the class and we would hang
out
and i would smoke you would smoke that's
right
um and then we would go in here
when it was class time yeah or if you
were late
you didn't have time to hang out here
and you just just went right in which
probably goes like me
that was me and then uh so
what do you remember i remember
we all sat in chairs here yeah that's a
bar now but that's where the stage was
and our teacher was cynthia segetti
brilliant
improv teacher and she sat here smoking
the whole the whole time and then
yelling commit
bigger and but lag the best laugh in the
world tim great laughs
when you knew you were doing something
right and he
she was blown away with you always
and she well and i've said this before a
lot of times i hope it's not boring
but i almost i i my first class he
wasn't
in it yet and i thought i don't think
this is for me she keeps saying commit
and people would just get like you know
bigger
and and i thought that's not for me i
don't think i can do this
this was maybe a bad career choice but i
made myself come back the next week and
i was late
and i sat there because you all were
already on stage
and she had you like do spaceball oh
that's right you have to pretend to lift
a
invisible disc but baseball spaceball
yeah and people were like
and then conan was just
throwing it better than what i just did
and she was so much better good
commitment and i went
that's commitment oh i can do that he
didn't make a fool of himself
right he just was ironic because then i
went on
to make a career out of making him fool
myself well we all did intentionally
uh but yeah it was really
magical and the reason i like to bring
this up
is you know people forget they look at
you now
and they think well how would i ever get
there that's
impossible and i just like to try and
remind people
yeah we were 22 and we were in this room
this was a money where you'd put cash
like 20 or whatever it was in a jar
i don't remember that i remember writing
checks
oh i gave her cash more money yeah yeah
i don't even think i had a checkbook
but we anyway we gave her money and then
we would sit here and we would do this
improv class
and then you and i would say let's go
get coffee and we would talk about
we want to do these really big things
and have a big career
and a lot of people whatever our
waitress must have thought well they're
deluded and insane
because i am a working actress exactly
that's where what many of them end up
doing but uh but it was really
i don't know i'm very fortunate i'm
really happy that i know you it's just
been a blessing i've been me too a
million blessings in my life but
uh i get very sentimental when i come in
here really cool
we've never been here together before
yeah now i mean
since 19. sorry 87 86 something like
that yeah
that's great but i'm sorry because this
i had to put this here why do i say i'm
sorry for
absolutely everything but um and
conan was sitting there and people are
up there
you know just figuring it out and
they're not great perfect or brilliant
yeah this is nice i'm really glad we
came back here
this is really sweet and uh
yeah i don't know just keep flogging
away at those dreams i say
yeah just look it's really cool you
don't know who you're gonna meet
you don't next truly you don't know out
of class or anywhere just like you were
saying you have no idea yeah
yeah no i have to say something else
important in case they think
it's not like we helped each other
professionally
at all right exactly but i tried to
stop you i tried to stop friends that's
another
book i kept i tried to crush it make
sure that it didn't exist but you
couldn't
couldn't it got too big too fast but
if i can finish my point sorry of what's
inspiring
is that what who conan was for me
figuring this out taking my classes you
know you're as an
actor performer you're finding your
voice you're right you're
you're honing in on what's your take
what's your
comedic voice and
when you have someone that you feel like
they get you
and and you can
play and riff riff is a word yeah
safely with someone and that's how you
find it
i mean that's how you zero in it i mean
zero in on it mostly everything i do is
stolen from conan
kind of yeah sure yeah okay i think i
did take on some of you we all
humor we all do we all influence each
other it's like music that's how it
works yeah we all
pick up little things from each other
and you pick your influencers
yeah exactly yeah but i would like a
piece of
whatever you've earned at friends you
already got it i thought
no no i i want more well 60
[Laughter]
now